what do you need to raise money for
you've got to know what you need to
raise the money for if you're going
after investment capital and it has to
make sense for your business i got an
email from a youtube viewer says he
needs money to
launch his app company and the money is
going to be used for hiring a
professional app developer and one of my
suggestions so this is from
orestisd92
here's the problem if you are an app
company if you're a technology company
you're making apps
you need to have somebody on board who
knows apps
it's really hard to go out
to raise capital
for a company
that wants to make apps but doesn't have
anybody who knows how to make apps on
board does that make sense
if i was an investor
if i'm going to give you money i want to
see that you have this person already on
board on your team not that you need to
go hire somebody
this is a huge deal this isn't sales and
marketing this is creating your product
you need to have these skills
already on board on your team
or people aren't going to give you the
money to grow it so i see two options
for you here
okay number one partner up with an app
developer if you have great visions for
where you want to take the apps you have
some great mission that you want to
solve a huge challenge that you're
trying to help people overcome and
you're going to solve it through apps
partner up with somebody who has had
success and knows the app market and
needs somebody who can do the ceo job
who can do the sales and marketing you
have to bring something to the table for
your company what is it
it's not going to be the technical
skills so find somebody to partner up
with who has the same belief and same
believes in the same mission that you're
all about
and bring them on board then go get
capital
because it's really hard for an investor
to put money into a company where you
don't have the core competencies already
there
the second option is to start a lot
smaller just get a little bit of money
and and hire an app developer
part-time on the side just to get a
product up with the longer term goal to
bring on a full-time app developer but
you need somebody technical
guiding the product
right as a vc i would never invest in a
company who didn't have their own
cto
right if you're a technology company you
need
an awesome technology engineer
guiding the product and the vision
you need them on board already it's okay
to have somebody come on and do the
sales and marketing you can hire for
that but
it's hard to have somebody
come on board to be your cto that's a
hard person
to find to hire and if you are
technology company without a technology
person
you don't have much to go with
so i'd really try to do my homework and
try to find somebody who could partner
up with because that's going to be your
longer term strategy for success
is having somebody who's invested in the
business who isn't just an employee who
this business means something to them
they're going to put everything they've
got into it because they have an equity
stake in the company and then from there
you can raise money
to help expand the business you have a
working product now you need to go on
sales and marketing it that's a lot
easier to raise
so good luck believe i know it's hard
and and really spend your time finding
the right person don't just jump into
something because you think it's a good
idea
it's gotta fit the person has to fit
with their skills and also their belief
and their motivation for starting the
businesses for the right reasons
believe
for those who watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think leave a comment
underneath it makes you want to do more
videos for you thank you so much and
i'll see you soon